[Music]
I haven't heard from Owen in 24 hours
your husband that's not who you think he
is
[Music]
what defines you
I ask first
there's nothing I wouldn't do for my
daughter
[Music]
Mrs Michaels Mr reckles asked me to give
this to you
[Music]
sorry ma'am the building's closed my
husband works inside I'm trying to reach
him
I haven't heard from Owen in 24 hours
where's my dad
I don't know what is that
[Music]
[Applause]
you okay I can't believe this is
happening your husband that's not who
you think he is why are you making him
sound like some criminal mastermind I
may not know why your father did what he
did but I know who he is he lied to me
and then he disappeared and I want to
know the truth
I'm telling you we'll thank him
and I can need to get out of there now
where did you get this tell me who sent
you go
yeah stepdaughter or an imminent danger
is there something you're not telling me
they need to stay together
[Music]